Joshua's with us in Fort Worth Texas hey
Joshua how are you I'm great are you
better than I deserve what's up so I
recently married I unfortunately played
the debt game and lost real hard when I
was 18 and so now kind of coming to life
she has a little bit of debt which we
student loans in a car and I have a car
that has some student loans and so I I
really want to get focused and ghazal
intense and I just don't know the best
way to talk to my wife about this i I do
sales for living and I know sometimes
that we just kind of have to wait for
the perfect opportunity and have the
right thing you know to say so I was
wondering if you could offer me some
fresh perspective as far as how to come
about this with my wife and sure how
much debt do the two of you have total
not counting your house so not counting
our house we have 40,000 of student
loans and then I about 10,000 a consumer
debt more about the cars hearts and such
on the cars I hope that was an online it
shows 9,000 other night you fell so
seventy thousand dollars what's your
household income somewhere between 110
or 120 excellent income okay how long
have you guys been married you've been
married for about six months and how old
are you 24 and she is she's 24th oh okay
cool all right well my son is 25 he's my
youngest okay and we're he to sit down
with his new wife were he to have a new
wife at that point six months and asked
me this exact question here's exactly
what I would tell him the first thing is
is you're a Salesman and she knows that
so she doesn't want to be sold yeah yeah
I just read your mail dude okay and so
just sit down with her and tell her the
truth and the truth is maybe I've been
studying this stuff well yes $70,000 in
debt I'm worried about it and I have
read that the number one cause of fights
in marriage and the number one cause of
divorce and marriage marriage is coming
to an end is money fights and money
problems and I would never want that to
happen to us so I think it's very
important
that we get on the same page you and me
and we make a lot of money for 24 years
old your household income is incredible
you guys are killing it Joshua we make a
lot of money honey and it's kind of sad
that we have this much debt and I think
if we were out of debt we could enjoy
our life more we could save more and we
could give more and I'd like to work
towards that and I want to know what
your thoughts are and just ask her some
to make a few statements like that ask a
few questions don't sell her and don't
wait for the perfect time just talk
about it this is one of the most
important things you're gonna deal with
in your marriage not because money is
important but because it's attached to
everything that is important and walk
your way through it so hold on I'm gonna
give you a copy of the book the Total
Money Makeover the two of you read
through that together and you'll have a
proven step-by-step plan to getting the
debt cleaned up but more importantly
being on the same page in your marriage
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]